the bitcoin market's exploding we hit
three all-time highs yesterday literally
can't stop won't stop bitcoin is only
going one direction we're in a bull
market what does that mean
price going up all right 66 921 this
morning up over two percent two percent
is now literally twelve thirteen hundred
dollars at a time eventually i
anticipate that we will start to see
five thousand dollar daily moves and
then eventually ten thousand dollar
daily moves that's both up and down it's
a highly volatile asset measured in us
dollar terms but yesterday up big and
hitting three all-time highs s p
basically flat gold silver euro yen
running b oil who cares nobody is
looking at those trash assets on top of
that if we go and we look at the market
cap bitcoin now is pretty comfortably a
1.25 trillion dollar asset we are
knocking on the door
you can hear us
we're knocking on the door of silver
silver's about 1.35 trillion dollars
bitcoin
we're knocking right on the door 1.26
trillion on top of that you can see the
settlement volume yesterday was off the
freaking charts almost 30 billion
dollars of bitcoin on chain settlement
volume that is monster numbers that
starts putting us up in the six seven
eight nine trillion dollars of
annualized
uh actual volume when you start getting
up to those numbers you start knocking
on the door of visa and mastercard how
much transaction volume they do on an
annual basis real exchange volume 7.6
billion and then active addresses
sitting comfortably about a million
active addresses per day now the mining
reward this is how much money the miners
were paid in the last 24 hours to secure
the bitcoin network 61.8 million dollars
the reason why this is important is
because as the price of bitcoin
continues to go up that u.s dollar
amount will continue to go up as well
they're getting the same bitcoin but the
bitcoin is worth more in u.s dollar
terms and so quite literally more and
more miners will continue to come onto
the network all competing for that 61.8
million dollars that was paid out in the
last 24 hours that means that the
economic incentive is driving the
bitcoin network to become more
decentralized and more secure over time
as warren buffett or charlie munger both
say show me the incentives and i'll show
you the outcome there is an economic
incentive for more people to secure the
bitcoin network and to continue to make
it more resilient to any sort of
external attack we go ahead and we look
at bitcoin the s p and gold all compared
side by side over the years well ladies
and gentlemen this is an absolute
massacre that is definitely the term
that you should use bitcoin up 340 year
over year gold is down four percent
nominal terms gold is down over nine
percent in real return basis now the s p
up 32 but what is so fascinating is
quite literally bitcoin has performed
10x better than the s p 500 over the
last year if you were sitting in cash
last year and you decided to go into the
benchmark of the us stock market and buy
the s p 500 that was great you made 32
times your mo 32 more of your money but
if instead you had went and bought
bitcoin you would have literally more
than tripled your money and 10x
outperformed your neighbor who simply
bought the s p 500 that is what we call
opportunity costs so bitcoin continuing
to be the apex predator of financial
markets it's big enough at over a
trillion dollars now for people to
allocate large sums of money and we will
likely continue to see exactly what
people are going to do there now when we
go ahead and we look at the bitcoin
price in closing history there's only
one day
ever that bitcoin's price has been
higher than it is right now and that day
was yesterday so literally every single
person who has bought bitcoin on any day
since january 3rd 2009 all the way up
till today any day that you bought
bitcoin if you held it till today
there's only one day where you would be
under in terms of the us dollar value
and that day was yesterday so if you
didn't buy bitcoin yesterday you have
more purchasing power today than you've
ever had because bitcoin has only ever
been higher since yesterday and that is
why this asset is structurally designed
to continue to protect your purchasing
power or increase it now when we go when
we look at bitcoin gold s p 500 nasdaq
and tlt what you see is the roi in of
the one year basis you can see it right
there in the middle 340 or so is
absolutely trouncing any other type of
asset including
gold ntlt both being down materially and
nominal basis then if you go out and you
look at the kaggar the compound annual
growth rate on the 10-year basis the
compound annual growth rate for the last
decade of bitcoin as we stand right now
it's 172 percent that is absolutely
bonkers i don't think we've seen an
asset that has grown like that that is
over a trillion dollars in a very long
time if ever i think this is probably
the first time in history we have had an
asset that is over 150 compound annual
growth rate for a decade and also over a
trillion dollars where institutions can
actually start to allocate to it that my
friends is very very important if we
then go ahead and we look willy woo
coming out with this contour map and
what i love about this map is that it
shows that every bitcoin at the price
that they were last changed hands
between investors the huge price
validation between 50 and 60 000 is
likely to cement bitcoin as a trillion
dollar asset class regardless of what
you think when you look at this data it
is simply showing that there is immense
support right around that one trillion
dollar mark which is 50 to 60 000
bitcoin price so today we sit
66 67 000 it's going to be hard to see a
world where we dip back way below 50 000
ever again never say never but there is
lots and lots of data points that are
suggesting there is great buying
interest right around that one trillion
dollar mark and so we ever dip back down
there expect people to be gobbling up as
much bitcoin as they possibly can on top
of that we've got the young wizard will
clemente in the last four months over
200 000 bitcoin have been moved off
exchanges according to glass note that's
equivalent to about 12.5 billion dollars
at current prices this is another regime
of outflows illustrating a broader shift
in dynamics for the bitcoin market after
march of 2020. so when we look at this
obviously everyone is very excited
bitcoin hitting three all-time highs
yesterday what do we think ends up being
the current state here we have dylan uh
leclair from bitcoin magazine coming on
in a little bit dylan is going to come
on and he's going to drop absolute bombs
in terms of market structure but what do
you guys think of the bitcoin market
right now and kind of how to think about
what some of these data points are
showing us well i think
certainly when we talked about earlier
when we started the show was around 30
000 or whatever and we've seen over the
last few months like that supply squeeze
has been building up will talks about it
every week dylan has come on and they've
talked about it and when you really just
look at the fundamentals right the the
the fact that 90 of all bitcoin that'll
ever be in existence is currently in
existence the rest of the 10 percent or
less than 10 at this point of time uh
won't be won't finish coming into
existence until you know 120 more years
2140 i believe it is and then 85 of the
existing supply and circulation right
now has been held for 90 days or longer
so just on simple supply and demand
economics is telling you that this price
has to go higher as more demand comes in
right and it feels like every single day
we're seeing more demand come in whether
it's simple things right tim cook said
this morning a deal book that we're
going to talk about later that he owns
bitcoin and ethereum and other crypto or
he owns bitcoin and ethereum and he sees
it as part of his diversified portfolio
so there that's an easy one then there's
countries buying bitcoin there's a bunch
of different things right the mayor's
government officials are all competing
uh to see who can take more of their
paycheck in bitcoin so when it comes to
demand like we're seeing more and more
of that every day and when you only have
to worry about one side of the equation
it makes it much much easier to think
about 200k coins have been moved off
exchanges correct we've been talking
about the supply squeeze it looks to be
coming into fruition um it's exciting
adoption is moving rapidly companies are
getting involved individuals getting
involved the supply is fixed price has
to go up to accommodate that this is
exactly what kind of people were talking
about during the summer q4 is here and
it's looking good for bitcoin